[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم ال سي
ابي عاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من جنين حيث
يستمر التصعيد الاسرائيلي في الضفه
الغربيه
وقوه الاحتلال توسع عملياتها وتقتحم مخيم
جنين وتقتل سته فلسطينيين
اما هذه الصور فتريدنا مباشره من باريس
حيث شهدت العاصمه الفرنسيه ومدن اخرى
مظاهرات واضرابات شارك فيها مئات الالاف
احتجاجا على تعديل نظام التقاعد
وهذه الصور تريدنا مباشره من لندن حيث
قدمت الحكومه البريطانيه مشروعه قانون ضد
الهجره غير القانونيه لمنع القادمين عبر
القناه للانجليزيه من طلب اللجوء في
البلاد
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
[تصفيق]
بالقذائف الصاروخيه والرصاص الحي ووسط
تحليق المروحيات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يقتحم مخيم جنين بالضفه الغربيه ويقتل سته
يقول ان بينهم منفذ عمليه حواره نتنياهو
يهدد بتصفيه من يمس حياه الاسرائيليين
المقاومه تقول ان ردها على جرائم الاحتلال
لن يتاخر والسلطه الفلسطينيه تطالب واشنطن
بالتدخل لوقف التصعيد الاسرائيلي وواشنطن
تعرب عن قلقها من تصاعد العنف
بعد يوم من اعلان مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه فتحه صفحه جديده مع طهران
ملف ايران يتصدر محادثات امريكيه
اسرائيليه رفيعه المستوى في واشنطن البيت
الابيض يشدد على تعزيز التنسيق لمنع طهران
من حيازه سلاح نووي والرئيس الايراني يدعو
اجهزه الاستخبارات في بلاده الى العمل على
مواجهه التهديدات
جدل استهداف خطي انابيب نوت ستريم يعود
الى الواجهه
تكشف عن معلومات استخباراتيه امريكيه تشير
الى ضلوع مؤيدين لاوكرانيا في التخريب
موسكو تعتبر ان تقرير الصحيفه يدعم
مطالبتها بتحقيق دولي ومستشار الرئيس
الاوكراني ينفي علاقتك ياس بالهجوم تقول
انها لن تستبق التحقيقات الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
بعد اشهر من معارك دانيه دون حسم روسيا
تقول انها متمسكه بالسيطره على شم هجمات
اضافيه في عمق خطوط الدفاع الاوكرانيه
وبعد نفي وجود انقسامات اوكرانيه بشان
ادارات المعركه هيام تتعهد بالدفاع عن
المدينه وترى فرصه لمواجهه القوه الروسيه
في مقابله خاصه رئيس وزراء مالي يكشف
للجزيره عن تفاصيل الانسحاب الفرنسي من
بلاده ويقول ان ابلاغ باريس برفض
املاءاتها كانت دافعه وراء قرار سحب
قواتها والانسحاب من اتفاقيات التعاون
ويشير الى معلومات دقيقه وادله لدى بلاده
على تواصل ارهابيين مع فرنسا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا قبل ايام من اكبر
مناورات عسكريه امريكيه كوريه جنوبيه منذ
خمس سنوات تحذير من كوريا الشماليه اي
اعتراض لصواريخنا خلال تجارب فوق المحيط
الهادئ هو اعلان حرب واضح
[موسيقى]
اذا اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاد
سته فلسطينيين برصاص قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في العمليه العسكريه كما اصيب
سته عشر فلسطينيا بجروح المشهد كما يراه
الجيش الاسرائيلي تضمن تفاصيل قال فيها ان
من بين من قتلهم في جنين منفذ عمليه حواره
التي قتل فيها مستوطنان الشهر الماضي قوات
الاحتلال قالت ايضا انها اعتقلت نجلي
منفذي العمليه فيما اعترف الاحتلال باصابه
اثنين من جنوده
ينضم الينا من جنين مراسل الجزيره سمير
ابو شمالي سمير كيف يبدو الوضع في جنين
بعد العمليه
رائحه بارون نعم هناك حاله من الغليان
والغضب الشعبي حيال استمرار قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه بهذه المجازر وهذه العمليات
العسكريه التي تستهدف من خلالها المدنيين
والمقاتلين
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه نحن الان نقف في داخل
منزل الذي تم محاصرته من قوات الخاصه
الاسرائيليه في بدايه هذه العمليه والتي
استهدفت من خلالها عدد من المقاتلين
المقاومين الذين تصدوا للقوات الاحتلال
والتي حاصرت هذا المنزل من عده مواقع هذه
ربما تشاهدون هذه بقايا الحجاره التي
تدمرت وتفجرت خلال اطلاق عدد من القذائف
الصاروخيه التي استخدمتها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه من عده محاور كانت خلال
حصارها للمنزل عدد من مقاتلين كتائب شهداء
الاقصى في هذا هذا المكان كانوا يتصدون
لقوات الاحتلال دفاعا عن المتهم من قبل
الاحتلال
المحرر على عبد الفتاح خروشي وهو احد
قيادات حركه حماس والدراعها العسكري في
مخيم العسكر بنابلس وهذه اثار الشهيد عبد
الفتاه خروش الذي استشهد وهذه الدماء هي
الموقع الذي استشهد فيه الشهيد عبد الفتاح
خروشه في هذا المكان بالتحديد عندما كان
يقاتل جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيليه هذه ايضا
اثار للرصاص الذي استخدمته القوات
الاحتلال في الدخول الى المكان وهذا
المنزل من خلال المحاصره وايضا الاشتباك
مع الفلسطينيين المقاتلين في هذا المكان
الجيش الاحتلال ايضا هو استخدم القوه
المفرطه في هذا المنزل وقد استخدم ايضا
العديد من القذائف الصاروخيه من عده زوايا
دمرت الكثير من محتويات المنزل وايضا
كان هناك عمليات ايضا تصدي من قبل
الفلسطينيين شبان وفتيا في خارج او نطاق
المنزل وفي محيط المخيم وذلك للتصدي لهذه
القوات الاسرائيليه ربما تشاهدون ايضا هذا
المكان هو مطبخ المنزل الذي حاصرته قوات
الاحتلال والذي استشهد على بابه الشهيد
خروشي وهو المتهم بقتل الاثنين من
المستوطنين في بلده حوار جنوبيه نابلس قبل
نحو عشره ايام
الفلسطينيون هنا في حاله غضب وايضا احتقان
لدى هذه العمليات العسكريه المستمره من
قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه وزاره
الخارجيه والرئاسه الفلسطينيه دانت هذه
العمليات العسكريه واكدت انها هي تصب في
نطاق الحرب الشامله ضد الفلسطينيين وطالبت
المجتمع الدولي بوقف جميع هذه الجرائم
وهذه الانتهاكات سواء من جيش الاحتلال او
من المستوطنين
وتدخل الفوري والعاجل للجسم هذه
الاعتداءات وهذه الانتهاكات ضد
الفلسطينيين الفلسطينيون في هذه
العمليه العسكريه الجديده والمجدره التي
ارتكبت بحق الفلسطينيين قدموا سته شهداء
وهم غالبيتهم من المقاتلين الذين تصدوا
القوات الاسرائيليه التي تسللت بشاحنه
تجاريه الى محيط المخيم جنين وحاصرت هذا
المنزل وقامت
القذائف الصاروخيه هذه الاثار كما تشاهدون
هي اثار ما تبقى من
القذائف التي تم
ضربها واطلاقها على هذه هذا المنزل الذي
كان يتحسن فيه الشهيد خروشه ايضا رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه في هذه العمليه قد
حيا ما وصفهم بالمقاتلين الشجعان في جيش
الاحتلال وايضا قال بهدد بانه وحذر من ان
المساس بالقوات الاسرائيليه والمستوطنين
والمواطنين اسرائيل سيقابل بالقتل في اي
مكان وفي اي زمان للحفاظ على او حمايه
المستوطنين وجنود الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
هناك حداد قد اعلن من قبل الفصائل
الفلسطينيه واضراب شامل يوم يوم غد في بعض
المحافظات الفلسطينيه وذلك حدادا على
ارواح من سقطوا من شهداء في هذه العمليه
العسكريه الجديده في مخيم الجليل شكرا لك
اذا سمير ابو شمالي من قلب المنزل الذي
شهد عمليه الاقتحام حيث كان يتحصن الشهيد
خروشي في مخيم جنين شكرا جزيلا لك
كيف دخلت قوه الاحتلال المخيم جنين وكيف
نفذت اقتحامها وكيف تصدت لها المقاومه في
المخيم
[تصفيق]
منفذ عمليه حواره صيد ثمين تلاحقه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من مدينه لاخرى في
الضفه الغربيه بشكل متزامن يقتحم جيش
الاحتلال جنين وينفذ عمليه عسكريه في
نابلس قال الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي
انهما تتعلقان بعمليه حواره التي ادت
لمقتل مستوطنين في السادس والعشرين من
فبراير الماضي الزخم الاكبر للعمليه
العسكريه كان في مدينه جنين ومخيمها قوات
كبيره من جيش الاحتلال تتقدمها وحدات من
الكوماندوز والقوات الخاصه المستعربين
توغلت ظهر الثلاثاء في قلب جنين جيش
الاحتلال اصدر بيانا مقتضبا قال فيه ان
قواته تخوض عملا عسكريا في جنين دون ان
يوضح طبيعته توجهت قوات الاحتلال مباشره
الى مخيم جنين وحاصرت احد المنازل في شارع
مهيوب عند اطراف المخيم
اشتباكات عنيفه اندلعت بين مقاومين
فلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال قصفت قوات
الاحتلال خلالها المنزل المحاصر بصاروخ
كما دفع الجيش الاسرائيلي بطائره مروحيه
بغرض عمليات الاجلاء من موقع العمليه في
حين غطى الطائرات الاستطلاع سماء المنطقه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في جنين اعلنت اسقاط
مسيره شاركت في العمليه وتفجير عبوات
ناسفه باليات الجيش الاسرائيلي من مسافه
صفر وبالتزامن مع العمليه العسكريه في
جنين دفع جيش الاحتلال بقواته الى مخيم
عسكر في نابلس حيث حاصرت القوات
الاسرائيليه منزلا واعتقلت فلسطينيين
اثنين قالت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه انهما
ابناء منفذ عمليه حواره
[موسيقى]
ان جيش الاحتلال قتله فلسطينيين بينهم
منفذ عمليه حواره في اقتحام نفاده
بالتعاون مع جهاز الامن العام الشباك كما
اعترفت اسرائيل باصابه اثنين من جنودها
خلال الاشتباكات
في التسلسل الزمني للاحداث تم ترابط بين
جنين ونابلس ذلك ان عمليه حاجز حواره وقعت
في اليوم ذاته الذي نفذ الاحتلال فيه
الاقتحام الاكثر دمويه لجنين منذ اجتياح
عام 2002 وفي التصنيف الامني تضع اسرائيل
نابلس وجنين كاكثر المناطق خطوره في الضفه
الغربيه لم تكن عمليه حواره قبل عشره ايام
حدثا عابرا لاسرائيل لا في مكانها ولا
توقيتها ولا سرعه تنفيذها في مربع امني
وعسكري لجيش الاحتلال والمستوطنين
وبعيد انتهاء الاقتحام الشاد رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي
واكد انها اسفرت عن القضاء على منفذ عمليه
حواره جنوبيه نابلس قبل عشره ايام مجددا
تهديداته للفلسطينيين بالقول ان من يمس
بالاسرائيليين سيقتل
قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه نيد
برايس ان واشنطن على علم بهجوم المستوطنين
على بلده حواره معربا عن قلقه من استمرار
اعمال العنف في الضفه الغربيه واسرائيل
اضاف برايس ان الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
يستحقون الحريه والامن والازدهار وان هذا
يظل هدفا بعيد الامد فيما يبقى الهدف على
المدى القصير هو ضروره ان يقوم الطرفان
بخفض توتر فورا وبشان اجتياح مخيم جنين
قال برايس ان اسرائيل لديها الحق في
الدفاع عن شعبها واراضيها ضد جميع اشكال
العدوان بما فيها عدوان وجماعات الارهابيه
على حد تعبيره مؤكدا ان الولايات المتحده
قلقه من تصاعد العنف في الضفه الغربيه
وانها تواصل حث الاطراف على اتخاذ خطوات
فوريه للحد من سقوط الضحايا
ينضم الينا من رام الله الدكتور غسان
الخطيب استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
بيرزيت ومن واشنطن معنا ريتشارد المبعوث
الخاص السابق للرئيس بالكلانتين الى منطقه
الشرق الاوسط مرحبا بكما دكتور غسان
الخطيب اذا عمليه اقتحام باستخدام القوه
المفرطه تحت غطاء عسكريا كثيف
يعني لملاحقه ومطارده منفذ عمليه حواره ما
الرساله الاسرائيليه من وراء كل ذلك
الرساله الاسرائيليه ان هذا المشهد الذي
شهدناه اليوم في جنين والذي ادى الى وقوع
سته شهداء اصبح نهجا شبه يومي
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بشكل عام
وتهدف هذه الكثافه
الاستثنائيه والغير مسبوقه للعمليات
العسكريه العدوانيه التي تتخذ شكل التصفيه
لانه شطاء الفلسطينيين تصبح نهج يوميا
وتهدف الى ايصال رسائل
للجانب الفلسطيني للشعب الفلسطيني
بان العنف الفلسطيني او المقاومه
الفلسطينيه ستواجه
بقوه وبمزيد من القوه المشكله التي
يواجهها الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ان هذا بدوره
يولد مزيدا من ردود الفعل الفلسطينيه
المقاومه ويولد مزيد من التعاطف من
المجتمع الفلسطيني مع انشطاء الفلسطينيين
الذين يقعون ضحيه لمثل هذه الاعتداءات
والاقتحامات الاسرائيليه وبالتالي
حاله الصراع العنيف مرشحه ليس فقط
للاستمرار بل للتصعيد بطريقه لن تمكن
اسرائيل من تحقيق اهدافها على الاطلاق
في حديثه اليوم وكانه يغطي هذه العمليه
التي قامت بها قوات الاحتلال في جنين على
اساس انها تلاحق منفذ عمليه حواره ولكن
عندما يقوم الاحتلال
بعمليات اقتحام تؤدي الى مقتل عشرات
الفلسطينيين كما راينا منذ بدايه هذا
العام منذ وصول حكومه نتنياهو
بشكل عنيف لا نسمع نفس مستوى الادانه
لماذا
واضح ان اداره بعيدا تحاول
تحافظ على نوع من التوازن راينا مؤخرا ان
عضو مجلس الشيوخ وهو
الديمقراطي الاساسيه في مجلس الشيوخ شومر
وهو يهودي ويمثل الكثير من اليهود في
ولايته نادره ما يسافر الى الخارج لكنه
ذهب الى القدس والتقى نتانياهو وقال
وبشده مع عدد من اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
الاخرين
انما يقوم به في الضفه الغربيه وكذلك فيما
يتعلق
بموضوع القضاء واستقلاليه القضاء امر غير
مرحب به انا اعتقد ان اداره بايدن تنقل
راس سائله الى حكومه نتنياهو مفادها ان
استخدام القوه هذا
الذي يبدو او التي تبدو مفرته امر يجب
تخفيف منه وذلك لما في مصلحه اسرائيل
ما فعاليه هذه الرسائل التي تتحدث عنها ان
لم تقترن مع اي نوع من الضغوط
نحن لا نعلم ما يضغوطات التي تمارس خلف
الكواليس
طبعا الولايات المتحده غير مستعده وبصراحه
غير قادره على ايقاف نتانيا
من استخدام القوه وكما يقوم به فهو يقوم
بهذا الرهان المدروس حيث يظهر ان هذه
القوه تجعل الفلسطينيين او يحاول ان يظهر
ان هذه القوه سوف تجعل الفلسطينيه توقفون
عن استهداف الاسرائيليين سنرى وسنحصل ولكن
حتى الان لا يبدو ذلك فعالا ويبدو ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي
يدرك ان نتنياهو يحميه
ويسانده وبالتالي لا يتحرك بقوه ضد
المستوطنين الذين يعتدون على الفلسطينيين
والمناطق الفلسطينيه المجاوره طبعا هذا
امر اخر
قامشومر وغيره من السياسيين بالحديث عنه
واعتبروه سياسه غير حكيمه دكتور غسان
الخطيب السلطه الفلسطينيه عادت وطالبت
واشنطن بالتدخل لوقف التصعيد الاسرائيلي
ما هي الانتظارات الفلسطينيه من
الامريكيين
في الحقيقه يعني لا يوجد توقعات عاليه لدى
الفلسطينيين من الولايات المتحده ولكن
الفلسطينيون وربما غيرهم كثيرون يعتبرون
الولايات المتحده مسؤوله جزئيا عن ارتفاع
وتيره التوتر
وعن الضحايا الذين يقعون نتيجه هذه
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه لان اسرائيل تمعن
في هذه الاعتداءات وفي هذه السياسه
المتطرفه بدعم متواصل ومنقطع النظير من
قبل الولايات المتحده
وبنوع من غض النظر على المستوى العملي
يعني اذا وضعنا الانتقادات اللفظيه التي
لا تعني الكثير بالنسبه لاسرائيل جانبا
يعني
الاداره الامريكيه يعني ينظر لها
الفلسطينيون باعتبارها طرف داعم لاس
وبالتالي تتحمل مسؤوليه جزء من هذا
التصعيد لذلك يتوجه المسؤولون الفلسطينيون
للمجتمع الدولي وبشكل خاص للولايات
المتحده لوضعها امام مسؤولياتها
لانها الطرف الوحيد الذي يمكن اذا اراد ان
يؤثر او يضغط على اسرائيل فاسرائيل مدينه
بتفوقها
وبغناها
وبتميزها للدعم الامريكي تاريخيا وفي
الوقت الحاضر وبالتالي الولايات المتحده
هي الجهه الوحيده القادره لوضع حد لهذا
الامر شكرا لك دكتور غسان الخطيب استاذ
العلوم السياسيه في جامعه بيرزيت من رام
الله وشكرا للسيد المبعوث الخاص السابق
للرئيس بيلنتن الى منطقه الشرق الاوسط
تامن واشنطن
[موسيقى]
بعد يوم من تاكيد المدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه ان فصلا جديدا قد
بدا في العلاقه مع طهران اكد بيان امريكي
اسرائيلي تعزيز التنسيق لمنع ايران من
حيازه سلاح نووي والعمل على وضع حد لما
سماه النفوذ الايراني فيما قال الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي ان بلاده تواجه
تهديدات شامله وحربا هجينه وان على
الاجهزه الاستخباريه العمل على رصدها
وكشفها ومواجهتها
نحو التفاهم سار خطوات حتى بدا لمسؤول
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان فصلا
جديدا قد بدا في العلاقه مع طهران لم يعد
الرجل من هناك بتوافق تام حول التفاصيل
كمساله حجم الزيارات للمواقع الثلاثه
الموصوفه بغير المعلنه والتي قالت الوكاله
انها عثرت فيها على اثار اليورانيوم
لكن الساعات القليله اللاحقه بشرت بمقاله
جروسي انها موافقه ايرانيه على السماح
للوكاله بالمضي قدما في اجراءات المراقبه
والتحقق من الانشطه النوويه امكن ذلك في
مستهل اجتماعات مجلس محافظي الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الدوري
لكن هذا الصنف من الانباء لا يطمئن بما
يكفي كبار المتوجسين من طموحات ايران
النوويه
تختار الولايات المتحده واسرائيل هذا
التوقيت بالذات لبحث الملف على اعلى
المستويات الامنيه والدفاعيه
والاستخباراتيه رئيس هيئه الاركان
الامريكيه مارك ميلي بحث في اسرائيل اخيرا
اهميه استمرار العمل لبنع ايران من امتلاك
اسلحات نوويه وجوله وزير الدفاع الامريكي
في الشرق الاوسط تتضمن مباحثات بشان
البرنامج النووي الايراني اما لقاءات
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي في واشنطن
مع نظيره الاسرائيلي ووزير الشؤون
الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه فانتهت الى هذا
التعهد تعزيز التنسيق لمنع ايران من حيازه
سلاح نووي وزياده ردع انشطتها الاقليميه
سيؤكد هذا التوجه الى ريب ما بدا للرئيس
الايراني انها تهديدات شامله وحرب هجينه
تواجهها بلاده وتستهدف انجازاتها كما قال
مع علم ايران كما يبدو بعظم ما تواجهه
يؤكد وزير خارجيتها مواصله بلاده الجهود
لاحراز نتيجه في محادثات اعاده تفعيل
الاتفاق النووي ولكن مع اخذ مصالحها
الوطنيه بعين الاعتبار وفق قوله ابلغ
الايرانيون كما قالوا الاطراف الغربيه بان
التوصل الى اتفاق يلتزم به الجميع ثابت
على اجندتهم دون ما تراجع عما يصفونها
بخطوطهم الحمراء
فعند اي خط سيقف الاسرائيليون والامريكيون
سمعوا انتقاد جروسى لتهديداتهم بضرب
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه اذا وصلت
الدبلوماسيه الى طريق مسدود وحتما بلغهم
قول القاده العسكريين في ايران بان اي
ضربه مباشره لبلالهم ستقابل برد قد يطلق
حربا عابره للحدود
معلم من مدينه ليدز في بريطانيا الدكتور
على مصالح استاذ دراسات ايران والشرق
الاوسط في الجامعه الوطنيه الاستراليه
دكتور عالم صالح مرحبا بك بماذا تنبئ وتشي
هذه الاجتماعات بين المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين والامريكيين في واشنطن في
هذه في هذه المرحله فيما يتعلق بايران
الطرفان قلقان جدا بالنسبه
للنشاطات النوويه الايرانيه ولكن الخطا
الاستراتيجي من للخروج الامريكي من
الاتفاقيه النوويه في 2018 هي اللي ادت
الى هذا القلق حينئذ في سنه 2018 ايران
كانت تقصد ايرانيا الى نسبه فقط 4% او اقل
منها واليوم ايران استطاعت ان ان
تخصيب اليورانيوم الى درجه
84% اي اقل بقليل من من صنع القنبله
العسكريه
فلذلك
من حق تل ابيب واشنطن يقلق لاخطائهم
الفادحه في 2018 لخروج من الاتفاقيه
والانسان وكانه لا يوجد ثقه لدى الطرفين
بالمسائر الذي تسلكه وكاله الطاقه الذريه
نعم في في اتفاقيه نوويه في 2015 كانت
هنالك اشياء عده لعده الى نجاح هذه
الاتفاقيه اولهم حصل ثقه تاريخيه بين
الطرفان وثانيا ان الطرفان اخذ بعين
الاعتبار المصالح الاخر ولكن اليوم غياب
الثقه في حين ان كل طرف
يركز على مصالحه اولا ثم مصالح الاخر ان
كان هنالك اي مصلحه لاخر ثم الظروف
الدوليه تغيرت جدا هنالك الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه واتهامات المتكرره ضد ايران
بانها تزيد او لتزويد الروس بالسلاح
الايراني هنالك مواجهه صينيه غربيه وفي
نفس الوقت هنالك
قدرات ايرانيه العسكريه ازدادت كثيرا في
ايران اصبحت قريبه جدا من القنبله النوويه
اي ربما هي
[موسيقى]
عن القنبله النوويه اللي بضعه ايام فقط لا
ننسى ان القنبله النوويه
التي استخدمتها امريكا اليابان في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه كانت النسبه التخصيب
فيها 80% فقط وايران اليوم
وصلت الى تقريبا 84% من تقسيم اليونان
فهذا شيء يغلق الكل شكرا لك دكتور على
مصالح استاذ دراسات ايران وشرق الاوسط في
الجامعه الوطنيه الاسترانيه ضيفنا من ليدز
في بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
نقلت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز عن مسؤولين
امريكيين قولهم ان مهاجمي خط نورد ستريم
العام الماضي كانوا على الارجح مواطنين من
اوكرانيا او روسيا او من البلدين معا ولم
يشارك في العمليه اي امريكي او بريطاني
وكشفت الصحيفه ان واشنطن راجعت معلومات
استخباراتيه جديده تشير الى ان مجموعه
مواليه لاوكرانيا نفذت الهجوم على خطوط
الانابيب ونقلت الصحيفه عن مسؤولين قولهم
انه ليس لديهم اي دليل على تورط الرئيس
الاوكراني
او كبار مساعديه في العمليه او ان الجناه
كانوا يتصرفون بتوجيه من اي مسؤول حكوميا
اوكراني
قال البيت الابيض ان واشنطن لن تستبق
التحقيقات التي يجريها الحلفاء الاوروبيون
بشان تفجير خط نوت ستريم وقال منسق
للاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي
تنتظر انتهاء التحقيق الاوروبي بشان تفجير
الخط من جهته قلمياك مستشار الرئيس
الاوكراني انه لا علاقه لبلاده بالهجوم
على نورت ستريم ولا معلومات لديها عن
الضالعين في العمليه اما نائب مندوب روسيا
بالامم المتحده فقد قال انما نشرته
يؤكد صحه مطلب روسيا بتحقيق دولي في تفجير
الخط
معنى من موسكو كان محرر وشؤون الدوليه
بصحيفه كوميرسنت ومن امتياز معنى
للديمقراطيه مرحبا بكما سنبدا معك سيد
سروكان كيف وجدت هذه المعلومات التي كشف
عنها
لم تنشر فقط في نيويورك تايمز ليست
الوحيده التي نشرت هذه النسخه الجديده عما
حصل مع نوت ستريم فالصحافه الالمانيه ايضا
سربت اخر
كشف عن الموضوع صحيفه ديبسايد بالنسبه الى
هذه التسريبات الاخيره كان يفترض ان تجيب
عن اسئله ولكن المفارقه
هي انها اثاره المزيد من التساؤلات
اذا نظرنا الى هذا التسريبات وقارن ذلك
بالتقارير السابقه
التي حيث ان صامويل هرش وهو فائز بجائزه
بوليودزر قدم صيغته الخاصه فنرى ان هذا
التقرير هو ضعيف لانه يثير الكثير من
الاسئله بدون اجوبه اولا لماذا ليس هناك
ذكر لاي اسماء محدده السؤال الثاني ليس
واضحا من هذه التسريبات هل كان هناك دوله
تقف خلف هذا الاعتداء او انها جهات من غير
الدول واخيرا والاهم هناك اعتبار تكون هنا
وهو
بحسب المحللين طبعا ان هذه التسريبات ربما
هدفها الالهاء وترشيط الانتباه عن رئيس
بايثون وعن الرئيس زيلانسكي من اجل ايجاد
مجموعه لا اسم لها تكون مبهمه والقاء
اللوم عليها وهذا ما سنسال به السيد بيتر
زلمايرف سيد بيتر بدايه هذه المعلومات
الاستخباريه هل تحرج اوكرانيا بما انها
توجه بطريقه او باخرى الاتهام لها
بالنسبه الى الاتهام انا اوافق المتحدث
ضيف الكريم الذي نادرا موفقا راي نعم فعلا
تقرير
يطرح المزيد من الاسئله ولا يعطي الاجوبه
ولا يشفي غليلا اكرر هو لا يلقي اللوم على
اي من الجهات من خارج الدول او من غير
الدول ربما هي مجموعه
الغير مرتبطه بدوله ولكن لديها تعاطف مع
اوكرانيا هذا كل ما يلمح اليه اضيف
الاوكرانيه
من عساها تكون هكذا مجموعات
تدين بالولاء لاوكرانيا تنفذ عمليه بهذه
الضخامه بهذه الكلفه من دون ان تكون
السلطات الاوكرانيه ضالعه في ذلك يعني هل
توجد مجموعات من هذا النوع
لديها هكذا امكانات
اخفاء شيء من هذا المستوى سيكون صعبا
وبالتالي ان تساعد الحكومه الاوكرانيه هذه
المجموعه وتوفر لها مساعده امر يعتبر
خطيرا جدا او مجازفه كبيره بالاحرى اذا
تبين بحسب الصحيف او حسب مقالته الصحيفه
ان اوكرانيا ضالعه فان دعم المانيا
لاوكرانيا سيكون معرضا للخطر نظرا لان راي
العام سوف يتغير
ولكن علينا ان ننتظر حتى تظهر القصه كامله
بالرغم من ذلك انوه بان كل ما نراه في هذه
التقارير بالرغم من كل ذلك المسؤوليه تعود
الى من بدا الحرب اهو الا وهو فلاديمير
بوتين وهو
بدون هذه الحرب لحافظ على علاقات جيده مع
كافه دول الغرب مشروع نوتسريم الثاني كان
يمضي قدما وهو الذي قتل طموحات ومستقبل
بلده الاقتصادي سيد
سروكان في ضوء كشف كل هذه المعلومات
الاستخباريه والتي تبدو غير مكتمله كما
ذكرت ووافق معك ضيفنا المتحدث من اوكرانيا
ما شكل التحقيق الذي تريده موسكو في ما
حصل ويمكن ان تثق بنتيجته
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان الموضوع لا يرتبط بموسكو وحدها
من فعلا يبحث عن اجربه حقيقيه
يريد ان يكونوا هناك تحقيق
شفاف وذات مصداقيه على مستوى دولي طبعا
كلنا نريد ان نعرف من قام بهكذا حدث او
عمليه ارهابيه هذا ليس امرا بسيطا ما
نشرته عن وجود
هذا يجعل كل هذا التقرير مضحكا فعلا من
سيصدق هكذا روايه
واذا قررنا ذلك بسامويل هرش الذي تحدث عن
الرئيس بايدن نرى الفرق اذا نحن لسنا في
موقع يتيح لنا مناقشه موضوع الرئيس بوتين
نحن في هذا الحلقه انه نناقش من يقف خلف
ذلك وطبعا بوتين هو اخر من يريد ان يفجر
الانبوب او خط الانابيب ما يتيح له
هو كان يسمح له
بالاستمرار في تجاره مع اوروبا ولكن هناك
جو ساعد هنا مافاده ان هناك حمله
اعلاميه من اجل تبييض صوره تويلميع سوره
الرئيس بايدن ودول المشاركه في ذلك تدعم
ذلك شكرا لك
وشكرا للسيد بيتر زلماياف مدير مبادره
اوراسيا للديمقراطيه ضيفنا منكيف
قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان الوضع في
باخمه صعب لكنه تحت السيطره من جهته قال
المتحدث باسم قياده القوات الشرقيه
الاوكرانيه للجزيره ان قرار القياده هو
الاستمرار في الدفاع عن المدينه نافيا ان
تكون محاصره
هذا وقال وزير الدفاع الروسي ان السيطره
على المدينه ستسمح لقوته بشن هجوم نحو عمق
الدفاع الاوكراني
قال رئيس وزراء مالي شوقي
ان بلاده لم تتخلى عن التعاون مع فرنسا
واكد في مقابله خاصه مع الجزيره ان
الفرنسيين ارادوا ان يفرضوا على الماليين
ما يقومون به وانهم قرروا المغادره بعد
مجيء حكومه لا تروق لهم على حد وصفه
اود التاكيد على اننا لم نتخلى عن التعاون
مع فرنسا ولكنهم ارادوا ان يفرضوا علينا
ما نقوم به وما نعتقده ونحن نقول لهم ان
هذا العصر قد ولى فنحن نختار شركاءنا
ونختار ما نقوم به الفرنسيون قرروا ان
يغادروا بعد مجيء حكومه لا تروق لهم
وكانوا يعتقدون اننا سنتوسل اليهم كي
يبقوا
كما قال رئيس وزراء مالي للجزيره ان لدى
بلاده معلومات وادله على ان بعض
الارهابيين الذين كانت الدوله تحاربهم
كانوا على تواصل مع فرنسا التي قال ان
تعاونها العسكري مع مالي لم يحقق ايا من
اهدافه المتفق عليها
لم يهزم الارهاب ولم تبسط سياده الدوله
ولم تطبق قرارات الامم المتحده خلال
الوجود الفرنسي هذا من جهه ومن جهه اخرى
لدينا معلومات دقيقه وادله ان بعض
الارهابيين كانوا على تواصل مع فرنسا
[موسيقى]
الى بريطانيا حيث طرحت الحكومه مشروعه
قانونا لمنع طالبي اللجوء الذين يصلون
البلاد بطريقه غير قانونيه على متن قوارب
صغيره من حقهم في طلب اللجوء المشروع
الجديد يتضمن اجراءات حكوميه لاعتقال
طالبي اللجوء وترحيلهم ومنع دخولهم
لبريطانيا مدى الحياه ونقلت وكاله الصحافه
الفرنسيه عن الامم المتحده قولها ان مشروع
قانون الهجره البريطانيه الجديد يرقى الى
حظر اللجوء فيما وصفت جمعيات حقوقيه
واحزاب معارضه المشروعه بغير القانوني
وغير العملي
احلام كبيره في قارب صغير طالب لجوء
يبحرون من فرنسا الى شواطئ انجلترا لكنه
وصولهم ترى فيه السلطات البريطانيه كابوسا
مؤرقا كلما ازدادت اعدادهم لهذا طرحت
الحكومه مشروع قانون يخورها اعتقالهم
وترحيلهم
اذا دخلت بريطانيا بشكل غير قانوني سيتم
اعتقالك وترحيلك بسرعه الى بلدك اذا كان
امنا او الى دوله ثالثه امنه مثل رواندا
هذا التشريع يمكننا من اعتقالهم دون
مراجعه قضائيه او افراج بكفاله لثمانيه
وعشرين يوما حتى ترحيلهم
الخطه تتضمن فتح معتقلات جديده بعضها في
قواعد عسكريه ثم منع المرحلين من دخول
بريطانيا طوال حياتهم منظمات حقوقيه عده
عرضت التشريع بقوه بينما اعتبرته احزاب
المعارضه غير عملي
بدلا من ملاحقه العصابات الاجراميه قال
نائب رئيس المحافظين انه يجب عدم ملاحقتها
لانها موجوده منذ الاف السنين هذا سلوك
معيب وحتى الان لم يعثروا على مئات
الاطفال المفقودين من فنادق ايواء
اللاجئين الذين اخذتهم العصابات
يبدو ان الجدل بشان قوارب المهاجرين
يتجاوز ابعاده القانونيه والانسانيه
ليتحول الى مسعا لتسجيل النقاط السياسيه
بين الحكومه والمعارضه فالقضيه تشغل نسبه
كبيره من الناخبين وفق استطلاعات الراي
وهي احد اهم التعهدات الانتخابيه لحزب
محافظين
رافا
هذه مثلا لقطات للتظاهرات في ليفربول
الشهر الماضي لنشيطين من مجموعات اقصى
اليمين في محيط فندق لايواء طالب اللجوء
في ع
نايه مثل اجتياح وسمعنا وزيره الداخليه
تتحدث عن ان ترحيل اللاجئين الى رواندا
بمثابه حلم لها هذه ليست لغه مسؤوله ما
نحتاجه هو حكومه ملتزمه بايجاد حلول
انسانيه وقبيله للتطبيق
ورغم اجراءات الحكومه وخطابها تستمر قوارب
الطالب اللجوء في الوصول كل يوم تقريبا بل
وتزداد اعدادها محمد المدهون الجزيره لندن
المهاجرون وطالبون اللجوء في بريطانيا
يصلون في الغالب عبر القناه الانجليزيه
التي تربط فرنسا بالمملكه المتحده في فقره
المتابعه سنسلط الضوء على هذا المسار وعلى
مساعي نبضا لالغاء هذا الخيار من حسابات
المهاجرين
في مزيد من الاخبار عبر العالم قال الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن انه تحدث مع سلطان عمان
هيثم بن طارق للتاكيد على الشراكه بين
البلدين ولتشريع التعاون في مجال التجاره
والطاقه النظيفه اضاف الرئيس الامريكي في
تغريده انه شكر سلطان عمان على دعمه انهاء
الحرب في اليمن وفتح المجال الجوي العماني
امام جميع الطائرات المدنيه ومن ضمنها
القادمه من والى اسرائيل
اعلن الديوان الاميري في قطر ان امير دوله
قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال ساني اصدر اليوم
امرا اميريا بتعيين الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن ال ثاني رئيسا لمجلس الوزراء وامرا
اميريا بقبول استقاله الشيخ خالد بن خليفه
بن عبد العزيز ال ثاني من منصبك رئيسا
لمجلس الوزراء ووفق الامر الاميري يتولى
رئيس مجلس الوزراء الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن الثاني حقيبه وزاره الخارجيه ايضا
كما تم تعيين خالد بن محمد العطيه نائبا
لرئيس مجلس الوزراء وزيرا للدوله لشؤون
الدفاع وعين الشيخ خليفه بن حمد بن خليفه
ال ثاني وزيرا للداخليه كما عين سعد بن
شريد الكعبي وزيرا للدوله لشؤون الطاقه
وعضوا بمجلس الوزراء
قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان ان التقارير التي تفيد بوجود
تباعد في العلاقات الاماراتيه السعوديه
مبالغ فيها ولا تدرك مدى عمق العلاقه بين
البلدين اضاف ان لدى السعوديه شراكه قويه
ومتينه للغايه مع الامارات رغم وجود بعض
الامور التي لا نتفق عليها بحسب تعبيره
واكد وزير الخارجيه السعودي انفتاح بلاده
على الحوار مع ايران وقال ان الاتفاق
النووي مع ايران ليس مثاليا وانه يجب ان
يعالج مخاوف دول الجوار اضافا ان هناك
حوارا لعوده سوريا الى الحضن العربي لكن
من المبكر الحديث عن ذلك
اتهمت منظمات حقوقيه بينها هيومن رايتس
واتش ومعهد البحرين للحقوق والديمقراطيه
اتهمت البحرين بانتهاك التزاماتها الدوليه
في مجال حقوق الانسان وحثه المنظمات
والبرلمانيين المشاركين في اجتماع وشيكا
للاتحاد البرلماني الدولي في المنامه على
ضمان ان لا تستخدم سلطات البحرانيه
الجمعيه السادسه والاربعين بعد المئه
للاتحاد البرلماني الدولي من اجل تبييض
سجلها الحقوقيه السيء بحسب وكاله الصحافه
الفرنسيه
شهدت مختلف المدن الفرنسيه احتجاجات على
مشروع لتعديل نظام التقاعد اقترحه الرئيس
ايمينيال ماكرون وتتركز المعارضه بصوره
خاصه على بند من هذا المشروع ينص على رفع
سن التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64
وكانت النقابات المهنيه توقعت شل البلاد
من خلال الاضرابات والمظاهرات حيث اعلن
الاتحاد العام
للشغل حظر خروج شحنات الوقود من جميع
المصافي بينما شهد قطاع النقل بالسكك
الحديديه اضرابات او اضطرابات واسعه
في شبه الجزيره الكوريه قالت بيونج يانغ
ان اي تحرك لاسقاط احد الصواريخ التي تجرى
عليها تجارب بل تجري عليها تجارب سيعتبر
اعلان حرب وارجعت التوتر المتزايد مع
كوريا الجنوبيه الى التدريبات العسكريه
المشتركه بينها وبين الولايات المتحده جاء
ذلك في بيان صادر عن
شقيقه الزعيم كيم جونغ اون التي لوحت
باطلاق مزيدا من الصواريخ على اهداف في
المحيط الهادئ
لغه التهديد والوعيد يتردد صداها في شبه
الجزيره الكوريه
الغاضبه من التحالف الامريكي الكوري
الجنوبي لا تفتح توجه رسائلها الصاروخيه
هذه المره يصمت الزعيم لتتحدث شقيقته
صاحبه النفوذ القوي بما ينطق به كيم جونغ
اون بل ان كلماتها بدت اكثر حزما وجراه
قالت كيميو ان اي تحرك عسكري لاسقاط احد
صواريخ التجارب الكوريه الشماليه سيكون
بمثابه اعلان حرب كما حذرت من ان بلادها
قادره على اطلاق مزيد من الصواريخ على
اهداف في المحيط الهادئ مضيفه ان تلك
المياه لا تخضع لسياده الولايات المتحده
ولا اليابان رغم ان التجارب للصواريخ
الباليستيه يحضرها مجلس الامن الدولي الا
ان الولايات المتحده وحلفائها لم يجازف
مطلقا محاوله اعتراضها وهو ما يعزز في راي
مراقبين مساعي الدوله المعزوله والمدججه
بمختلف الاسلحه لتحويل المحيط الهادئ الى
ميدان رمايه يمكنها من تطوير قدراتها
العسكريه في المقابل تستعد قواتنا امريكيه
وكوريه جنوبيه لاجراء مناورات عسكريه
مشتركه واسعه النطاق وعلى مدى عشره ايام
قبل ذلك اجرى الطائرات الحربيه الامريكيه
بينها القاذفه الاستراتيجيه ب 52 تدريبات
سريعه الثلاثاء مع طائرات جنوبيه مقاتله
ردا على ما سمته سول تهديدات كوريا
الشماليه بتدمير مهابط الطائرات
ترتيبات تصر واشنطن وحليفتها الجنوبيه على
انها ذات الطابع دفاعي بينما تعتبرها
بيونكيان استعراضا للقوه وتصعيدا متعمدا
للتوتر بل وتمرينا على غزو اراضيها
واستهداف نظامها السياسي
[موسيقى]
نعود الى الجدل الدائري في بريطانيا بخصوص
مشروع قانون هدفه التصدي لموجات طالبين
لجوء عبر الموش وقناه المعش او القناه
الانجليزيه جزء من المحيط الاطلسي يفصل
بريطاني عن فرنسا ويربط بحر الشمال
بالمحيط الاطلسي طول القناه قرابه
563 كيلومترا اما عرضها فيبلغ 200 واربعين
كيلو مترا عند اوسع نطاق واربع وثلاثون
عند اضيق مجال قباله مضيق دوفر القناه
ضحلى نسبيا فيبلغ متوسط عمقها نحو 120
مترا وتوجد فيها العديد من الجزر الصغيره
من اشهرها جزيره جيرزي يمر اسفل بحر
المانش النفق المعروف باسمه نفق المونش
للسكك الحديديه الذي يربط فرنسا ببريطانيا
والذي تم تدشينه عام 94 وهو ثاني اطول نفق
تحت البحر في العالم من خلال رحله
بالخطيره جدا وصل الى بريطانيا خلال العام
الماضي وحده 45 الف طالب لجوء عبر الموش
على قوارب صغيره وضع رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشيسوناك ايقاف القوارب
الصغيره ضمن اولوياته الخمس الرئيسيه بعد
ان تعرض لضغوط من نواب حزبه في البرلمان
لايجاد حل لتدفق طالب اللجوء الى بريطانيا
بحرا عبر القناه الانجليزي
مشروع القانون الذي طرحته حكومه سوناك
اليوم يهدف لمنع المهاجرين الواصلين
بطريقه غير قانونيه الى مملكه المتحده من
تقديم طلبات اللجوء والاقامه لاحقا على
اراضيها او طلبات الحصول على الجنسيه
البريطانيه
ويسهل مشروع القانون احتجاز المهاجرين او
طالبي اللجوء حتى ترحيلهم الى دوله ثالثه
تعتبر امنه ويمنعهم بشكل قاطع من امكانيه
الاستئناف ضد عمليات الترحيل اما طالب
اللجوء القادمون بطريقه قانونيه فستتعامل
معهم لندن على اساس حصه سنويه يحددها
البرلمان وهذه ليست المره الاولى للتعامل
مع هذه المشكله ففي العام الماضي اقر
الرئيس الوزراء البريطاني السابق بولس
جونسن خطه لارسال عشرات الالاف من طالبي
اللجوء الى رواندا التي تبعد عن بريطانيا
اكثر من سته كيلو متر لكن هذه الخطه تواجه
عقبات قانونيه حتى اليوم
ينضم الينا من ليفربول فرانكو
عميدو كليه القانون في جامعه ليفربول سيد
فرانكو ماذا يقول القانون عن هذا المشروع
الذي تتبناه حكومه سوناك بحق اللاجئين
هذا المقترح وهذا المشروع مشروع القانون
يسهل اكثر بكثير
ترحيل بكل بساطه ترحيل كل الذين يريدون
دخول بريطانيا بطريقتين غير قانونيه حين
يصلون يتم توقيفهم
وارسالهم واعادتهم بدون امكانيات
الاستئناف
طيب ولكن يعني ما طريقه وما سبيل الذي
يمكن لبريطانيا ان تحمي نفسها كما تقول
السلطات من اللاجئين غير النظاميين خصوصا
ان المجال النظامي لطلب اللجوء مفتوح
تكمن المشكله في انه في الوقت الحالي
لدينا الكثير من الاشخاص الذين يقطعون هذه
القناه ولا يمكننا ان نميز بين
المهاجرين لاهداف اقتصاديه
ولاجئين لاهداف سياسيه الذين فعلا يحولون
الهروب من الاضطهاد وهذا يزيد المشكله
تعقيدا ان صح القول ولكن
نحن ملزمون بتعهداتنا
الدوليه ولا سيما
الاتفاقيه الخاصه باللاجئين التي تعود الى
العام 1951 وهي تعني انه لا يمكننا بكل
بساطه ان نغلق الباب في وجههم او حين
يعبرون الباب نعيدهم ونرحلهم ليفترض بنا
نقوم بذلك بدون ان اكتشف اولا ما اذا كان
لديهم فعلا حقوق لاجئين او ليس لديهم اي
حقوق باعتبارهم
مهجرين طيب هل يبدو لك هذا المشروع مشروع
القانون المقترح سالكا ويمكن ان يمر في
الظروف الحاليه
انا اعتقد انه سوف يمر في البرلمان
الانجليزي بدون ادنى شك لان الحكومه تمتلك
الاغلبيه ولكن السؤال الفعلي يبقى
ماذا سيحصل بالنسبه الى التزامات بريطانيا
الدوليه ولا سيما اتفاقيه حقوق الانسان
الاوروبيه
وطبعا هذا سؤال منفصل تماما اعتقد ان
بريطانيا
وعلى المستوى الداخلي سوف تواجه الكثير من
الصعوبات وكذلك على المستوى الدولي شكرا
جزيلا لك فرانكو
عميد كليه القانون في جامعه ليفربول ضيفنا
من ليفربول شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
على بعد دقائق او ساعات من الثامن من مارس
حسب مناطق وجودكم ما زالت الهوه سحيقه بين
الرجل والمراه في كثير من مناحي الحياه
الرواتب مثلا ما زالت مقياسا رئيسيا لتلك
الهوه واستنادا الى دراسه اعدتها شركه
برايس
فان الفارق في الرواتب بين الجنسين تقلص
بنقطتين ونصف منذ عام 2011 وبات في حدود
14% في يومها العالمي تتذكر المراه ان بعض
الحكومات الغربيه بالدرجه الاولى اعتمدت
المساواه في تولي الحقائب الوزاريه دون ان
يعني ذلك بالضروره تساويا في جوانب منها
الرواتب بالوتيره الحاليه قد تتساوى رواتب
الرجال والنساء بعد خمسين عاما من الان
كما تقول الدراسه ولنا ان نضيف ما لم تكن
في المناطق المعنيه بهذا النقاش ليله
سعيده لكم ومبارك للمراه يومها العالمي
شكرا لمتابعتكم الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]